Det var väldigt mycket gasat bromsar i början.
Jag visste inte vad jag gjorde, egentligen.
Allt var helt nytt.
Jag köpte in en batch, sa då slut på den, köpte in en till batch, sa då slut på den.
Men första året omsatte jag tre miljoner, andra fem miljoner.
Så det var en bra start.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni omsatte 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kollegor, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Casper Kaldenby-Nag, från MyBlend till podden Makes Wins Stronger.
Tjena Casper.
Tjena, tjena.
Tack så mycket, kul att vara här.
Ja, vi har ju faktiskt satt en gång för, det är ganska många år sen, det måste vara typ sex år sen eller någonting.
Vi såg oss i, vi bodde både i Majerna och drev e-handel och så vi, jag tror bara vi satt och snackade lite grann i typ någon timme eller något sånt.
Ja, men exakt, det har vi faktiskt satt två gånger.
Jag började på lunching också, jag ville luska lite i dina SEO-kunskaper.
Då snackade jag till andra lång och käkade tajmat.
Ja okej, det kanske är den gången jag tänker på då.
Och så käkade vi frukost en gång.
Jaha, gjorde vi det?
Okej, då blandade jag bara ihop.
Jag har ju blivit en svensson, ni kan ju ha flyttat ut till Mönnlycke, men du bor kvar borta i Majina.
Det stämmer, det stämmer, jag bor kvar i Majina.
Tycker du om det som Majina har blivit med 3L och alla de här vackra restaurangerna, eller tyckte du om de gamla ölhaken med öl för 25 spänn och folk som slogs?
Alltså lite mer åt det hållet skulle jag vilja säga.
Det är någon viss charm i det.
C2-punder överhållar lite på morgonen.
Det är inte okej ändå.
Många gånger när vi bodde där så har jag vaknat av att folk stod och skrek utanför fönstret.
Det var liksom, jag kände att när jag fick mitt andra barn att nu är det dags att dra kanske.
Ja, jag kommer säkert att göra samma sak när jag ska få barn någon gång i framtiden.
Det ingår på något sätt i det där, men absolut vi kan, jag gillar alltid att alla som, man kan minna Majina med någon sorts nostalgi som att det är charmigt att folk dricker bärs och typ kissar på gatan.
Men det är lite misär ändå.
Ja, lite grann kanske.
Skitsamma, men det är där de flesta av oss har bott någon gång.
Men kan du ge oss lite bakgrund om Casper?
Vem är den här Casper?
Ja, men det kan jag.
Jag fyller 31 på lördag, men jag kan säga att det är 30 år idag i alla fall.
Så 30 år gammal, bor i Göteborg.
Jag är en e-handelsnörd kan man väl säga.
Det har blivit lite av min identitet de senaste åren.
När jag inte jobbar så har jag fått fram att det är kul att springa oerhört i mitt långa stäckor.
Så jag kör ultramarathon.
Jag håller på att träna inför mitt tredje nu.
Så det blir mycket löpning och jobb.
Så kan man sammanfatta mitt liv just nu.
Hur långt är ett ultramarathon?
Tekniskt allt över ett marathon.
Så du springer 43 kilometer för att låta lite cool typ?
Så det gjorde jag faktiskt på den här lördagen.
Men förra året körde jag 105 kilometer lockbara norra.
105?
105, ja.
Och 82 kilometer i Ulisand.
Vad har man för, fan vi ska inte prata för mycket om löpning, men 105 är ju ändå en vettig sträcka.
Det är en respektabel sträcka.
Vad har man för miltid på 105 jämfört med vad du kan springa mil på?
Extremt långsamt.
105 var ju uppe i bergen så det var ju konstant upp och ner, 6900 km.
Det låter ju fräckt att säga att man sprang det, men det var ju väldigt mycket gånger också.
Så det är att ta sig runt, men fan det tog mig typ 31 timmar att ta mig runt.
Så det var liksom konstant kämpande.
Ja, det var ju roligt.
Men när du kör den här som var 80, sa du att du sprang en på 80 någonting kilometer?
Ja.
Var det på planmark?
Det var på relativt planmark, ja.
Men det var lite annorlunda format.
Det var ett backyardultra heter det.
Då springer man 6,7 kilometer varje hel timme.
Så kommer mål in i nästa hel timme, så får man vila restrerande tid.
Så det här var max 12 timmar då.
Så då hade jag ungefär 10 minuter vila efter varje loop på 6,7 kilometer.
Vill man inte egentligen bara springa på?
Jo, man blir ju sugen.
Det är ju en jämnhet i utdraget att bara ligga där och nöta.
Jag ska ju köra en sån nu i sommar som inte har något slut.
Så där får man verkligen se hur länge man orkar ligga och tugga.
Det kan ju pågå länge som helst tills det bara är en person kvar.
Som springer en sträcka då?
Eller ett exa antal timmar och så får man se om man springer förbi den sträckan.
Ja men det är så här, alla ska ju komma i mål på den här 6,7 km-lopen inom en timma.
Skit i det där loppet, det nya loppet som ni ska springa.
Ja men det är...
Det är samma?
Det är det här formatet, exakt.
Så där kan man ju liksom ligga i ett dygn eller mer och bara liksom ta sig runt den här 6,7 km-lopen om och om igen.
Vad gör du under tiden?
Du springer i de här loppen, lyssnar du på något eller springer du bara och tänker på typ blommor?
Under de här loppen har jag väl mestadels inte lyssnat på någonting.
Men det som händer är att efter ett tag så kommer man in i någon typ av stadie där man typ inte tänker på allt som annars stressar den.
Typ med jobb och liksom vad det nu kan vara.
Så det blir ganska konkret att det handlar ju mer om överlevnad och det kanske är lite det jag söker, att man på något sätt kopplar av.
Det låter ganska absurdiskt att koppla av under sådana här omständigheter, men det blir ju lite det.
Men är du en sån här, är du en sån tech bro-nisse som David Goggins fan som måste testa ditt pamben och vakna klockan fyra på morgonen?
Eller är detta liksom, är detta det enda du gör som är weird?
Alltså jag skulle inte kalla mig en tech bro men jag skulle också ljuga om att jag sa att David Goggins inte har inspirerat mig lite åt det här hållet.
Och det är ju någonting som fascinerar mig med att se vad man är kapabel till på något vis.
Sen när jag har gjort det då kanske jag hittar på något annat.
Det går ju lite i fase med det jag sysklar med.
Men vaknar du upp på morgonen, tar en kalldusch, sätter på, vad heter han, longevity i snubben?
Brian Johnson.
Ja, sätter på det i bakgrunden, tittar in i en röd ljuskamera och sen, är det så ditt liv ser ut?
Jag ser igenkännande skratta här.
Jag vet att det är så här.
Nästan, jag gick upp halv sex idag och sprang sju kilometer i stadsgården.
Hur långt sprang du halv sex?
Sju kilometer.
Ja okej, vilken jävla sopa du är.
Jag vet, jag vet, det är ingenting.
Jag har inte nämner det egentligen.
Är du klar för dagen då eller kommer du springa eftermiddag också?
Jag är klar med att springa.
Jag ska dock simma med en kompis på lunchen, annars är det ingen mer löpning idag.
Okej, bara sju kilometer.
Jag menar det, ja det är faktiskt.
Herregud, okej men vi ska inte fastna, men normalt sett när folk pratar träning så blir det alltid jättetråkare.
Jag har givetvis pratat träning många år innan jag hade gymkompanier, men sånt här kan ändå fascinera mig där folk drar det till en nivå.
När folk säger att de vill träna för att se bra ut, så är jag såhär, ja okej, ja kul.
Eller ja jag vill träna för att bli stark, ja roligt, men jag vill träna för att kunna springa i 10 mil.
Det finns ju liksom ingen vettig relevans bakom, utan då är det ju mer en såhär intressant fixidé på något sätt, och då är det ju mer någon sorts märklig psykologisk effekt man är ut efter.
För jag har svårt att se att, speciellt om du springer i olika höjd, alltså springer du det där i olika höjdmeter, så är ju inte det en för kroppen skön utmaning.
Det är ju inte så att kroppen bara njuter efter de där 31 timmarna.
Du hade ju antagligen ganska ont dagen efter.
Ja fy fan ja absolut.
Jag var ont i knät de sista 7-70 kilometerna.
Så det är ju ganska weird, jag håller med dig.
Det är bara fascinerande.
Hur länge har du hållit på med det där?
Vi ska inte fastna i detta men vi började några minuter tidigt så att ni andra får spola fram.
Jag tycker det här är kul.
Hur länge har du hållit på med det där?
Drygt två år.
Jag har väl löpt till och från innan.
Men jag sprang först till Borswara för två år sedan.
Och sen så är mitt första varatan och sen då hade jag väl liksom eskalerat efter det.
Det är ändå en ganska snabb upptrappning.
Vad klarar kroppen det?
Den gör konstigt nog det.
Jag tror att kroppen klarar mycket mer än vad man tror.
Det är ju bara så länge man kan vara bekväm med lidandet så kan man nog pusha den jävligt hårt.
Så länge man tar kallduschen och lyser in röja ljuset.
Jag fattar, jag fattar det.
Okej, nu lämnar vi det privata.
Nu går vi in på MyBlend.
Vad är MyBlend för någonting?
Det är ett varumärke som jag startade för snart sju år sedan.
Vi säljer primärt en trådlös smoothie mixer.
Vi har även lanserat en lite mer sladdig modell med en sladd.
Men tanken är ju att introducera smidiga hussovsprodukter inom det här varumärket.
Du fick liksom en ganska stark start får man ändå säga.
När du drog igång detta så gick det jävligt fort fram.
Då är du 24 bast när du drar igång detta.
Och så vet jag att du sålde för typ några hundratusen på typ två veckor eller någonting och du gjorde massa influencer samarbeten.
Kan du ge mig upp starten lite grann, lite bättre, summerat än vad jag gjorde?
Det blev ju en bra start, det var ju en timing grej, dels för att det var en helt ny produkt.
Det var ingen som sålde den på svenska marknaden när jag lacerade.
Influencer marketing var ju fortfarande ganska effektivt.
Då jag hade blivit inspirerad av, om man vill kalla det som Daniel Wellington och de här branscher som byggde upp med influencer marketing och då tänkte jag att det här känns som en given kanal att testa.
Så jag beställde in en batch på 100 stycken.
Eller innan det så köpte jag in 10 samples faktiskt.
Och så jobbade jag som säljare på den tiden och knackade dörrar.
Och då tänkte jag att om jag gör liknande sak på Instagram, om jag DM'ar folk som är potentiella kunder och ser om de vill köpa.
Och så fick jag mina första sälj, 5, 6, 7 sälj via att jag DM'ade folk.
Och då såg jag att vafan, det finns ju någonting att ta på här.
Bara random människor eller?
Random människor innan träningen.
Det här vill du köpa i smoothiemixer.
Nästan, men det var lite mer typ så här, hej vet inte vad du märker, jag har precis lanserat en hemsida, om du ger lite feedback på den så kan du få en abattkod och gratis frakt på ditt köp.
Och så konstigt låg så folk svarade på det.
Men efter det så köpte jag in 100 stycken mixers, skickade ut 20 stycken mixers till 20 rekreatörer och hade liksom kolonerat att alla skulle lägga upp under samma fredag som den var första maj.
Jag tror det var fredag.
Då var jag på en gruppjobb i Växjö och då sitter jag med två kollegor dagen innan och dricker bärs i hotelllobbyn där och en kollega säger till mig såhär, fan, Casper jag tror inte det här kommer att flyga, jag tror inte det kommer att lyckas med det här.
Och då visar jag att jag blev så...
Vilken skön kollega.
Det här är faktiskt ganska skönt, men det var ändå lite osjukt sagt.
Men då är de orden, fan, jag blev så jävla sänktad om och tänkte shit, alltså om inte det här funkar då vet jag inte vad jag gör.
För det var kanske det tionde projektet som jag hade försökt mig på, där det var lite så halvdanna dropshippingförsök tidigare.
Men dagen efter så är jag i alla fall på ett kundbesök och så märker jag hur telefonen börjar klinga till.
Och så när jag kom ut från att se att ordrarna börjar rulla in och man hör det här Shopify-ljudet ka-ching och den känslan var ju bara såhär fucking amazing.
Nu visste jag att det här, nu har jag i mitt liv tagit en annan turn och sen tog det en vecka så sa jag upp mig för mitt säljjobb och bara körde all-in på Mylands MS Fan vad nice.
Och hur gick det sen liksom?
Hur gick första året, andra året?
Du såg liksom traction men det var ju inte så att du hade 800 sådana här smoothie makers till i pippen.
Nej precis, det var ju väldigt mycket såhär gasad bromsa i början.
Jag visste liksom inte vad jag gjorde egentligen.
Det allt var ju helt nytt.
Så jag köpte in en batch, sade och slut på den, köpte in till batch, sade och slut på den.
Men första året så omsatte jag tre miljoner, andra fem miljoner.
Så det var ju en bra start.
Hur kunde du omsätta tre miljoner första året?
Hur fick du in, för produkterna tillverkas väl i Asien?
Stämmer.
Hur fick du in leveranser såpass snabbt att du kunde komma upp i den volymen?
Hur fick du in de pengarna och hur fick du in den?
Jag hade ju sparat lite pengar för mitt säljjobb, men det var väl kanske 100 000.
Så allt gick bara, typ allt.
Sen körde jag flygfactor i början så jag började inte vänta på leveranser.
Okej, okej.
Såklart.
Factorna var ju lite billigare då.
Okej, för tre miljoner första året är ju en väldigt snabb...
Jag tror inte folk inser hur snabbt det är, men om man kollar på...
Det finns ju ganska många influencerbrands som har försökt börja sälja och då har ju de ändå en rätt stor publik.
Och så kommer de upp till liksom en halv miljon.
Alltså det behöver säljas ganska många produkter för att komma upp till tre miljoner.
För jag gissar att du har något snittårlig värde på den tiden på typ...
Jag gissar att den här låg på typ 400-500 spänn.
Ja, men absolut.
Absolut.
Det är någonstans runt där ja.
Så det var ju en del mixers, helt klart.
Och den här mixen som du tog fram då, vad var speciellt med den och vem var det som tog fram den eller var det bara en produkt du hittade?
Alltså version 1, om man säger så.
Vad var det för någonting?
Version 1, det var ju bara en vanlig white label-produkt som jag hittade på Alibaba.
Jag såg att, buspen med den var att det var en trådlös mixer och det var ju en ny produkt då.
På vänster sålde jag den i Sverige, som sagt.
Så jag gick in på Alibaba och bara skrev till alla jag kunde hitta som sålde den och beställde hem samples och valde att handla från den som hade typ bäst engelska.
Men fanns inte, när jag var liten då fanns det inte så mycket roliga tv-program.
Då kollade man på tv-shop och då fanns den här Magic Bullet.
Det fanns typ tre grejer som fanns.
Det fanns Magic Bullet, det fanns någon sån här AB-maskin och så fanns det väl typ några speciella knivar eller något.
Men var inte Magic Bullet en grej?
Den kanske inte var trådlös.
Nej jag kommer inte ihåg.
Nej precis, nej det är fortfarande en grej.
Alltså de säger fortfarande mycket om den men den var konstigt.
Men den var ju inte trådlös nej.
Det är bara såhär en kompakt.
Och den kanske är för liten också.
Ja men kompakt CD-mixer.
Jag för mig att det är en ganska liten variant.
Okej, men då gjorde du en white label.
Hur gick du vidare sen?
Sen så fortsatte jag på white labelspåret med modell 2 också.
Där stöt jag på lite patruller dock.
Det kan man ju se om man söker på Nordjabi på alla bolag.
Så kan man ju se att det var 3,5 miljoner sedan tredje året.
Var ner på 1,7 miljoner.
Och det som hände där var att El säkerhetsverket gjorde en marknadskontroll och har köpt in och granska den här produkten.
Så jag fick ett brev om att jag hade ett brev att hämta ut.
Och då vet man att det är någonting skumt som man ska hämta ut ett brev.
Så stod det att vi ska göra en kontroll på den här.
Så hela processen tog typ ett halvår.
Och sen fick jag svara tillbaka att det är för mycket att bli i lövningen på den här produkten och jag kunde inte fortsätta sälja den.
Men det var parallellt som jag höll på att utveckla MyBand 3 som vi säljer nu.
Eller liksom ändra en design upp med egen tooling på den.
Så det klaffade ändå ganska bra.
Men det året var ganska svårt.
Då hade vi ingen försäljning, typ åtta månader på det året kanske.
Då är du typ 26 år när det händer.
Jag bara tänker, du har sagt upp dig, du har gått från tre, du har gått till fem miljoner.
Du vet, det är ganska, du vet man är igång, man känner en sån här.
Jag gissar att du är i tankar.
Jag bara tänker hur jag själv fungerar där.
Du vet man börjar tänka, vilka nya produkter ska vi ta in, hur ska vi lansera där och där.
Man går in i växtfasen.
Hur hanterade du bakslaget där?
Det kan inte ha varit jävla bra för er gott.
Nej, det var jävligt jobbigt.
Jag var supernöjd vid starten, sedan första ett, två åren, då tänkte jag att ge mig två, tre år till så har jag sett, det här är hur enkelt som helst.
Sen kom det i och det var en jävligt stor klump i magen.
Det är ovissheten framförallt, där jag behöver återkalla alla produkter jag har sålt nu och händer det kommer det 100 procent att konka.
Sen var jag ändå tvungen att fortsätta köra på så jag tog ett banklån på en halv miljon för att kunna finansiera nya produkter också.
Det var helt klart jobbigt.
Men sen då, år fyra, kom den här nya då, My Blend 3, är det så jag ska kalla den?
Ja, precis.
Fick du igång säljet då?
Kunde du liksom fortsätta där du hade stannat eller blev det en, fick du liksom tänka om, kunde du fortfarande använda samma affärsmodell eller samma strategi eller blev det helt nytt?
Nej men det funkade ändå ganska bra.
Det är klart att det var ju mycket momentum som hade försvunnit och det var ju lite så här segstartat och försöka trampa upp igen och hade inte postat på Instagram på länge och nya annonser skulle upp.
Men det gick ju till slut.
Så det var ju jävligt skönt att det är barn.
Och då har det även fått in investering för att kunna köpa in ännu mer lager.
Så det var ju skönt att det gick.
Kan du berätta om den investeringen där?
Vad var det du sålde in?
Fick du det efter den här el-säkerhetsgrejen eller fick du det innan?
Nej men det var ju parallellt.
Men det var inte så mycket snack om det.
Det jag sålde in var mer i den tre och potentialen.
Och vad som hade gjorts och vad som kan göras framåt med den nya modellen.
Kan du inte berätta om investeraren där?
Vad var investeringen och vad var det de köpte?
Vad var det de tyckte om?
Hur var det att pitcha?
Ge mig så mycket som möjligt från den där tiden.
Det började med att jag satt hemma och googlade på affärsänglar i Göteborg, investeringar i Göteborg.
Så hittade jag Youngsure Invest.
Så jag mailade väl kanske 30-40 andra också.
Men de svarade i alla fall och sa att man borde söka till vår inkubator.
Så började jag googla vad det är en inkubator.
Så hittade jag att det är ett ställe där man kan få kontorsplatser, där man kan få lite mentorer.
Jag sökte in dit och så kom jag med i deras inkubatorprogram.
Så jag gick där eller satte där i kanske drygt fyra månader.
Vi lärde känna varandra så de visste vem jag var.
Det var ingen rätt hård pitch för just dem.
De fick ju lära känna mig under en tida.
Du vill inte dela några summor eller?
Du vill inte dela...
Är de den enda investeraren du har tagit in eller har du tagit in mer?
Nej, jag kan absolut läsa in mer.
De har gått in med en miljon totalt.
Men på senare år har även tre andra affärsängningar gått in också.
Det har varit bekantskapare till Matt Spejne som representerar Youngsure.
Hur är det att ha in en...
Visst är du ensam i bolaget som driver bolaget?
Eller har du anställda?
Nu har jag anställda.
Men fram till i slutet av förra året så har jag varit i princip själv.
Eller jag handlar med en tjej på kundtjänst.
Hon har rådda ränk, liksom en halvtimme och en timme om dagen kanske.
Vi har en kille som heter Gustav som jobbar halvtid också.
Och så har vi en tjej i Filipinerna som jobbar halvtid.
Nej, för det jag vill komma till är att...
Man kanske ändå ska säga att du upp och snurrar på typ 10 miljoner nu ish förra året och nu, eller på det senaste bokslutet som ligger upp i alla fall.
Så det har ju uppenbarligen vuxit till sig.
Men när man sitter på något sätt själv och jobbar absolut att någon är halvtid på en kundtjänst och så där, men då sitter jag ändå med rätt mycket beslut själv och rätt mycket rådande själv.
Och då helt plötsligt dyker upp fyra investerare som ska ha en åsikt om någonting.
Alltså det är ju på något sätt lättare, det inbillar jag mig, att ha investerare när du har många kolleger och du jobbar med en bredare, vad ska man säga, när du själv sitter i en mer översiktlig similjö.
Det måste vara lite skumt att jobba stenhårt i fem veckor och sen kommer någon investerare och du måste steppa ifrån och tänka stort på det här.
Håll käften typ, jag försöker fucking rådda en leverans där.
Exakt, jag är så gott ökad.
Nej men man har ju hört många sådana skräckhistorier men det har jag inte utlevt alls alltså.
Jag tycker Young Cher och alla inblandade har varit helt fantastiska.
Om något har de liksom varit typ för snälla.
Alltså de tror på mig stenhårt och de tror på mig ibland och bara stöttande.
Så det har varit jävligt gott bara att kunna bolla saker.
Istället för att sitta själv och försöka tänka att jag ska göra det här, ska jag göra det här och vara i rätt beslut.
Nu kan jag lyfta det med dem och diskutera så att det har varit jävligt bra faktiskt.
Jag tycker den här, speciellt nu senast åren med hela AI-grejen så känns det som att det är väldigt många som pratar om att nu kan du driva bolag upp tills du omsätter blablabla och du kan vara ensam och det kan vara ett e-handelsbolag.
Men bara för att du har en AI-tjänst som kan sammanställa info så måste du ju ändå göra rätt mycket jobb.
Vad är det som har varit knepigast att hinna med?
Vad är det som har varit eftersatt under den här perioden?
Ja, alltså det är allt som jag skulle få säga nästa.
För det som har varit jobbigast för min del det har varit att veta vad jag ska prioritera.
Det finns så mycket saker som jag bör springa på här och nu och liksom veta vad är prio och sen att ha någon typ struktur.
När man sitter och jobbar själv är det lite lätt med att ha en sån här vagneri och det är lätt att få mig att kanske fastna i och släcka bränder och det är någon del av mig eller något möte.
Så det har väl varit en stor flaska just med prioritering skulle jag säga.
Känner du att du kommer ut i det?
Börjar du lära dig eller är du fortfarande i släcka bränder-fasen?
Jag har absolut blivit bättre på det, definitivt.
Det togs ett litet tag, det är lättare sagt än gjort.
Sen kommer in grejer som folk som rycker i och vill ha en uppmärksamhet, men att man får vara med.
Nej, nu sitter jag och gör det här, nu får allt annat vänta.
Så det har jag blivit bättre på, helt klart.
Vad är det du har, bara så att folk förstår.
Sen säljer du lite små grejer runt omkring det, men det primära du säljer är en mixer, är det så du kallar det?
Ja, precis.
Det är en ganska spesad eller nischad produkt.
Vad är det som gör att du har lyckats nå ut med den?
Det finns ju, absolut, du var tidigt in på den, men det måste ju finnas fler trådlösa mixrar, du säljer inte bara i Sverige.
Vad är det som gör att folk köper just den här mixen?
Det kommer väl ner till marknadsföringen då.
Men som du säger, det har kommit andra konkurrenter som har startat genom åren och försökt göra samma sak.
De har hållit på några månader, ett halvår kanske, men sedan gett upp.
Men jag har ändå varit konsekvent.
Man kan väl sälja det mesta egentligen, om man bara syns och finns framför betonisera kunder.
Så det är bara ett jäkla nötande med marknadsföringen.
Vad är det du gör rätt med marknadsföringen då?
Det är en mycket bra fråga.
Jag tror väl att det är att våga testa mycket nytt.
Jag kan ställa mig framför kameran själv och vara med på annonser, och försöka vara personlig, och försöka vara rolig, och liksom inte lägga någon prestige eller ego i hur det ser ut.
Men ja, testa mycket nytt.
Det är väl en uppslag man har när man är så pass små som jag är, att man kan vara snabbfotad och testa mycket nytt.
Så det har varit en framgångsfaktor, helt klart.
Men jobbar du fortfarande jättemycket med influencers, för det vet jag att du gjorde när vi pratade, och du verkade göra det i början.
Är det fortfarande så eller är det mer ni själva som står för allt content idag?
Nej men alltså influencers, de började ju fatta sen att de kunde ju ta med betalt för sin reach, så det var inte mycket effektivt.
Ja, då var det liksom.
Okej, då får du skifta om.
Så det har varit mycket meta-annonser och mycket Google-annonser nu.
Men nu sitter vi återigen och försöker få upp ett influencerprogram eller mer kreatörsprogram kanske, sida ut produkter och hitta kreatörer som kan skapa bra content, som vi sen kan boosta på meta.
Så det är en lite annan take på det.
Vi är inte samma som det var i början, bara skicka ut produkter och med rebuttkod och mäta säljaren.
Nu är det lite mer skicka ut produkter och försöka hitta kreatörer som skapar bra content som vi sen kan använda i annonser.
Och vart säljer ni någonstans?
Vilka länder eller marknader?
90 % i Sverige.
Sen har vi, ja mycket här.
Sen har vi börjat sälja, Finland är den största marknaden.
Så där håller vi på att bearbeta nu.
Sen har vi haft lite spitt i Europa också.
Vi hade ju ett samarbete eller en licens, hur kallar jag det?
Vi gjorde en design med mumin.
Och den kollektionen har ju gått helt okej i andra marknader.
Det har ju varit, de känner igen mumin som varumärke och då får man förtroende därifrån.
Men vad är det som gör att det är så Sverigecentrerat?
Eller vad är, detta känns ju som en produkt som lika ena skulle kunna säljas i Norge eller Danmark eller Tyskland, eller alltså vart som helst.
Ja men exakt, exakt.
Ja men alltså från starten, så det tog mig väl kanske fyra månader efter lanseringen innan jag försökte gå in i Tyskland.
Och det var ju aldrig så tidigt.
Och sen såg jag ett eftertryck att gå in i USA och det var också aldrig så tidigt.
Så det kommer väl att leta liksom att fan, det finns mycket kvar att göra i Sverige där vi är så pass, eller är så pass små.
Så då har det mer varit liksom, vi fokuserar på det vi har nu och så är det väl liksom nu som vi känner att vi kan gå med till andra marknader också.
Men jag tror det finns, man kan göra mycket i Sverige också.
Vad ligger framtiden, ligger den i fler och fler marknader eller ligger den i fler och fler produkter?
Alltså du pratade förut om olika hushållsprodukter.
Är det en breddning i sockument som ligger närmast i tiden eller är det fler marknader som ligger närmast?
Vad ligger du och tänker på på kvällarna?
Både och.
Både och ger på gång, det kommer att komma nya produkter i det här året.
Och det ligger självklart att tänka på hur vi kan ut mer till andra marknader också.
Jag fattar att man själv tänker att om vi gör en blender då kan vi lika gärna göra en vattenkokare.
Jag säger inte att det är en vattenkokare du ska göra.
Det är lätt att tänka att det är en hushållsprodukt, men man bryr sig köparen.
Bara för att du har sålt en mixer, skulle de vilja köpa något annat?
Finns det någon koppling eller måste du börja om då?
För en av nackdelarna med den här mixen måste vara att det är svårt att få någon sorts återkommande kund på det.
Men bara för att man har sålt en mixer, är man sugen på att köpa en bröros då?
Nej precis, ja men det ska vi ta reda lite på.
Sen kanske det får finnas någon liten närmare koppling än och springa helt till något annat.
Då blir det verkligen som en omstart.
Men det kommer väl ner till det här också.
Om man har bra marknadsföring och kanske byggt upp något förtroende och de har sett varumärket tidigare så är de kanske mer benägna att köpa från MiveLand än någon helt annan som de inte känner till exempelvis.
Men nej det ska bli spännande att ta reda på det.
Ja, så sitter vi inte på någon svar än.
Nej jag förstår, det är bara intressant.
Jag tycker att det alltid har varit sådär 50-50.
Vi har också testat massa olika kategorier genom åren som liksom har känts helt logiska för vi säljer och så har vi bara upptäckt att det inte är samma kund.
Och sen de har testat någonting och så är det så här, ja det var exakt samma kund.
Det kändes inte logiskt i huvudet men det blev logiskt i efterhand.
Har ni gjort tester på mer säljsprodukter typ?
Jag såg att ni sålde något protein som var i ditt egna.
För det låg som slutsålt nu så jag gissar att ni inte tar in det igen då.
Nej, exakt det sålde vi inte superbra.
Det var primärt det som har tagit ut svängarna lite.
Sen hade det varit lite tillbörsprodukter till mixen.
Någon skyddsväska, extra lock och extra flaska, sugrör och de ligger väldigt nära.
Men ni har inte gjort frukt-
och bärmixar i frysformat och liknande?
Nej, jag har varit sugen på det.
Jag har sedan provat på det och haft tankar på att göra det.
Men proteinprövet kom före.
Men det var absolut felkund.
Efter att vi började köpa in det så valde vi kriget i Ukraina.
Alltså inköpspriserna ökade brutalt och marginalen försvann helt och konkurrensen.
Det var såhär, vi har ingenting här att göra.
Jag bara tänker, det känns ju som en sådan här, du vet, de här hälsobloggar, människorna, det är klart de ska ha en mixer och då ska de sälja in massa frysda bär också i någon sorts månadsprenumeration.
Har ni någonsin varit inne och pratat i sådana här samarbeten?
Alltså jag har ju varit sjukt sugen på att göra det, definitivt.
Men det har ju varit en prio-grej.
Så vet jag inte om det är rätt att gå det spåret heller.
Men det är klart att det lockar.
Det är säkert inte rätt.
Det är bara en sån där grej man tänker på.
Exakt, exakt.
Man gillar den idén att återkomma en kund och köpa och det är en premionation och det bara rullar.
Om det var så enkelt hade någon annan gjort det kanske.
Ja, säkert, säkert.
Det hoppas det.
Hur jobbar ni, är det bara er e-handel eller säljer ni liksom, är ni även en grocist till, jag vet inte, Elon?
Säljer ni till kedjor och sånt också?
Ja, jag har sålt lite till hälso-
och kostbutiker och lite andra online-
och återförsäljare, några Moomin-butiker.
Men det har varit en ganska liten del.
Förra året så sålde vi kanske 600 000 B2B.
Men det har också varit en sån grej att jag inte har haft tid att råda det riktigt.
Men det finns säkert mycket potential där, om man lägger ner mer tid på det.
Jag är en lager-nerd, jag tycker sånt är spännande, hur man finansierar och skit.
Framförallt är jag väldigt imponerad av den här uppstarten som du gjorde, om du kunde gå till 3 miljoner på första året.
Det är ju lite halvbizarrt på en ny produkt.
Men när du hade den här dippen där år tre och sen kom igång år fyra, hur löste du det?
Var det med lån eller investering?
Du nämnde att du tog in ett lån på en halv miljon eller något sånt där.
Och sen fick du investering i det.
Hur ligger ni och taktar?
Hur mycket har du på konto?
Hur löser ni det idag?
Nu har vi kommit in i ganska bra rullians med framförhållningen på leveranserna.
Det har varit en stor grej att vi inga mer flygfrakter med hjälp av ministerierna och lånet initialt så kunde vi göra ett större inköp och få lite mer snurr på hela det flödet.
Men det är en stor utmaning.
Vi har en jässanproduktion i Kina och ledsidor, Suezkanalen har omstängd då, båtarna i Tvarangadlundberg, det tar vi tid.
Ja exakt, nu har det varit snöstorm, det har varit lite problem med omlastningar.
Men tar ni hela containrar med mixer?
Det har varit mycket delad containrar, sedan nån har 20-fotare, men inte riktigt kommit upp till att ta en 40-fotare än.
Det blir en jävla massa.
Hur funkar det med, jag testade att importera typ lådcyklar en period, jag tänkte vi skulle börja sälja det som ett sidobolag, då hade vi lite problem med att få in batterier.
Det var krångligt, hur funkar det?
Det funkar ganska bra, det krävs ju testrapporter på batterierna, men sånt har ju på plats.
De är inbyggda också i produkten och är väl enklare om de har varit separata, då är det väl lite fiskare krav.
Så det är inga större bekymmer.
Hur funkar det med design och produkter och sånt?
Är du nere och pratar med fabrik och fixar sånt, eller kommer de med förslag, eller har du varit där och kikat och testat, eller vill du bara ta mig lite in i design och produktion, så nu om det är nya produkter, hur har du hittat dem?
Du behöver inte säga vad det är men bara...
Nej men jag har ju varit i Kina 2, åkt ner till den här stora Canton Fair, den stora inköpsmässan de var där, och liksom har lyskat nya fabriker och besökt befintlig fabrik.
Och just med produktutveckling, ja men det har varit lite...
Båda delar.
MyBand 3, den produkten, så anvittade jag en produktdesigner från Upwork, som egentligen skulle ta fram CAD-filer som jag sen tog till fabriken, de tog fram prover och fram och tillbaka.
Sen en annan fabrik som vi har inget samarbete med nu, där har de varit väldigt hjälpsamma med att ta fram de här designerna, liksom utifrån Nida Önskemål då.
Ja, båda delarna där.
Har du någon känsla för det eller har du jobbat med något sånt där innan, eller är det bara, ja men det här är bra, den ska kunna krossa is.
Ja, nej men typ så.
Jag vet ju inte riktigt vad jag gör egentligen, tänkte jag säga.
Nej men det är väl lite så känsla att bara scanna marknaden och se liksom.
Sen är det ju främst designer som vi påverkar själva liksom, motorn och moderkortet och liksom allt, batterierna och liksom, det kan ju de så jävla bra.
Så det får de stå för.
Och sen, jag bara inbilla mig att sekunden du börjar sälja någonting och folk ser din sociala medier så kommer de gå in på Alibaba och säga att de vill ha en kopia på den där.
Hur många sådana varianter har du varit med om och kan man skydda sig mot det eller bryr man sig eller gör man ingenting med det eller vad gör man mot alla tjugoåriga lycksökare som sitter hemma hos sin mamma och importerar.
Och speciellt under dropship trenden som väl lite har dött av nu.
Men det var ju en period när det var helt bizarrt och alla skulle starta dropship-butik.
Och då överlovade det ju rätt många.
Det måste vara rätt svårt att slåss mot liksom.
Hur har du bemött allt det?
Exakt, jag vet att det är första åren i början då tog jag lite åt mig lite såhär men fan, nu kom inte in i en kräk det här liksom.
Nu är jag som suger den här och det är lite orolig över konkurrensen.
Nu tycker jag mest att det var synd om man var i en in på den här produkten.
Det finns så mycket annat vi kan säkert lösa med.
Fan så mycket lättare.
Så lycka till.
Nej men det är svårt att skydda sig också.
Vi har ingen IP eller patent eller någonting på produkten.
Nej, det är bara att fokusera på det man kan påverka.
Kanske paketera den bättre med olika...
Vi kör en del tillbörspaket och sådana här saker.
Fokusera på marknadsföringen och bara gör det vi kan.
Jag tycker att det är jävligt kul att nästan alla som driver bolag tycker typ synd om folk som kommer in i samma bra.
Det är samma inom träning då såklart.
Det finns ju alltid folk som vill starta sitt egna träningsmärke eller sina egna produkter.
Och så ser man dem köpa in och så köper de in tre containerar och det är ju dyrt så in i helvete.
Och det är liksom långsamt omständigt och så om du ska ha till exempel hantlare ett hantelsätt då måste du ju ha 20 tyngder i lager och du måste ha 100 av varje och så är det alltid en sak som säljer slut.
Säg för att CrossFit Games säger att vi ska ha 17,5 kilo som är jätteudda storleksar.
Då tar den slut, då är det ingen som köper de andra för man köper inte hela sett.
Och så ser man på sin stackars konkurrent att de ligger där med ett lager på en halv miljon och säger såhär, fan kompis det här skit i detta.
Gör något annat istället.
In en lampa liksom.
Ja, börja sälja sopa eller sängkärror eller något sånt.
Det är fan så mycket lätt att räkna.
Det är bara kul för folk som lyssnar för mycket på Yandex bar där igen.
Vad, 2026, hur ser 2026 ut?
Vad räknar ni om att omsätta här?
Vad kommer hända?
Vad ligger i pipen?
När kommer de stora släppen?
Är det nu du kommer gå ut i media och bli den nya golden boy?
Vad händer?
Det tror jag inte riktigt.
Jag tror det är mycket fokus på att bara dels göra mig lite mer oberoende av alla beslut som tas, och låta Gustav ta lite mer plats i företaget.
Första lanseringen kommer väl i början på april och sen kommer någon i början på sommaren där.
Managet är planen bara att fortsätta göra det som är gjort bra med marknadsföringen, fortsätta växa 20-30 procent, och liksom göra alla tråkiga saker som behövs göras och bara nöta på.
Fan vad spännande.
Vilket engagerande, jag fattar precis, det är ju så det funkar.
Det är ju inte så jävla spännande egentligen, nöta på men ja.
Hur många gånger har du fått höra från dina föräldrar eller dina polare att marknaden måste ju vara mättad nu eller?
Ja men det har man hört många gånger, och det har vi hört från mig själv många gånger också.
Det är första året att folk fortsätter köpa.
Sen har man väl insett att det finns mycket att göra.
Folk har ju köpt nicksvars i säkert 60-70 år, då kommer det fortsätta att göra det säkert 60-70 år till.
Så det är bara konsekvent att nöta på.
Gött Casper, stort tack för att du var med i podden.
Kul att vara här, tack!
Vad gör du under tiden du springer i dom här loppen?
Lyssnar du på något eller springer du bara och tänker på typ blommor?